it's the biggest dream come true
this
I just I think we were all very
overwhelmed and moved by the response
and um
you know I I I meant what I said when I
was when I was a kid
I was 10 years old I remember I didn't
know much about world Cinema I didn't
know about the canned Film Festival but
I knew about Pulp Fiction and I knew
about Tarantino and the fact that he had
won an award for this crazy movie that I
wasn't allowed to see until I snuck over
to a friend's house and his mother
allowed us to rent it
um
and uh and and through that I discovered
the Cannes Film Festival I discovered
French Cinema World Cinema and
um and I had a dream to to come here and
uh
last night was just one of the most
moving and emotional experiences I could
ever have and to be here with this cast
who I love so deeply and
it just it meant the world to us so
thank you you know thank you Sam thank
you Sam
this project and these people mean
um everything to me and we really have
become like a like a family and so to be
here all together celebrating something
that
um means so much to all of us was like
just couldn't have been more special so
thank you for your metal videos like
Abel
yeah I mean we get to be surrounded with
the people that I love
um we've been working on this for for so
long and you know a few years ago I used
to come to the Cannes Film Festival and
watch it from the audience and
experience it
and seeing how overwhelmed everybody was
and
I would look at them and be like look at
these guys crying I mean I can never cry
in front of all these people
and then of course once I looked at Sam
and Lily I was just
fell apart because
I know I love them I love everyone
involved
and um
everyone's reaction to it was
heartwarming you know so
thank you guys
I think I you know I initially wanted to
make
um
like a a Dark Twisted fairy tale with
the music industry and everything I know
about it
um and heighten it and take you know
inspiration from
from
films that both me and Sam love
but it was it was really both our love
for for music
um when I found out how much
Sam is involved with the music in
euphoria
and getting to work with him on the
music on the show I think that's when it
really unlocked it for for the both of
us that we wanted to really focus on
um
how can we create our own pop star can
we create
um somebody who is trying to find
themselves and um using my experiences
using his experiences as an artist using
Lily's experiences from her point of
view
um and just you know creating something
special daring exciting
fun you know
make people laugh
piss some people off you know it's just
um
yeah that was that was the initial
initial thought and I've always wanted
to work with Sam I mean
we were friends before anything so yeah
okay you want to write something
I I mean I've had I saw Abel I think
perform for the first time at the
Hollywood Bowl
in 2011 or 12 and
I remember seeing him there and he he
was standing behind the mic and he he
didn't move
and I I was just I was captivated by him
and I I followed his career
you know as everyone knows his career
and you know I was following his career
and but I didn't get to see him again
live until
um until we were we were uh in prep for
um for this show and I went with him to
Coachella I think he hadn't performed in
in a couple of years maybe since the
Super Bowl
and I rode up with him I rode in the car
with him I watched the sort of the focus
and the ambition that he has
um you know listening to his his set
list on the layup and you know being in
in in the trip doing his vocal lessons
and just this this drive that he has to
to entertain and to give people the
greatest show possible
and I I I was out there in the audience
and I remember he said something to me
beforehand he said look you have to
remember he you know this was a this was
a festival that he he you know he wasn't
initially going to headline and he he
signed up for it in the last you know it
was about a week or two before before it
um
uh before was to go on and he and he
said this isn't this isn't my audience
they're not here to see me
but I'm gonna win him over
and he got up on that stage and he said
it's a tough audience because they've
been there for three days they're tired
they want to go home they got headaches
they're dehydrated he went up on that
stage and it was the first song started
to play and I could see people were
there but they you know they weren't
totally moving yet and I just I watched
them as he was just going out and he
just started to work the crowd and every
single person in that crowd he'd make
icon I mean not obviously every single
person but he was making eye contact and
he was singing and it was like by the
second song people started to loosen up
the third song they just started to give
themselves over to the music to the show
to the performance
and and I was watching them on these big
monitors and his face and the Charisma
and the and just how much he had grown
as an artist from when I first saw him
10 years earlier and I thought wow you
know this is the Arc of of a career here
you know this is and he's only what 32
33. this is the First Act
and I thought this
if he can if he can do this if he can go
from being this kind of shy kid behind a
microphone to this Superstar
this on stage he's he's got something in
him that
is
one in
you know a hundred billion and I'm I'm
really excited for for everyone to see
uh
where where this show goes
um
because he's a fascinating character
it's hard to pinpoint
like exactly the inspiration but
um
have I encountered anyone like Tedros I
don't
I think so no he's uh
he's pretty uh if you had I don't think
you'd be here yeah I don't think so yeah
thank God I feel fortunate that I've I
haven't run into anyone like him
um
but yeah inspiration I mean the the
first thing I can think about is is
Dracula you know he's just uh
he's Dracula you know and he's just
luring
um his uh his his what's the character
you're actually playing Lily
yeah
the girl the girl you know I don't know
if I'm allowed to say the character okay
but he's you know he's like lowering her
and then I I just the shot of him
when the garage door opens the gate door
opens and it's just like I couldn't tell
if everyone in the theater was laughing
because me and Sam and Lily were
laughing really hard at that best shot
ever but um
right off the top of my head Dracula
yeah